salve ragazzi sono con il signor gatto
buon sordi comunque non è tanto quello
ma noi facciamo video una volta si e poi
sei mesi 6 mesi no però quando noi
facciamo cioè quando li facciamo una
roba incredibile comunque sapete tutti
la mia passione per il maghetto della
rowling depero gatling hanno fatto bruno
cycling che sarebbe il quidditch è fatto
uomo di rocket league non saprei come
spiegarlo infatti hanno delle cause
legali in corso molto probabilmente da
entrambe le parti veramente draw però
vedrai partito cioè c'è del plagio
perché perdiamo assi si apre di fatto
sia per note clivio facciamoci mancare
niente
eccolo qua come dio allora cosa ci si
muova ceo lo spazio si fanno le piroette
lo spam
se tenendo premuto spazio si va anche
verso l'alto premendolo una volta sola
si va su prego prego fai vedere
e vero contro il si va giù malik
sinistro si dà la magia
lo schianto il flip and oil filipe con
il destro vincente di trasporto che è
nascosto perché non si fa scusa eh no
con la palla non si può a mi scusi con
lei invece si smagnetizza la palla
quando sia abbastanza vicini e siti
della sicilia ok quindi come si tira con
il grilletto sinistro ma mi perdoni
riletto va bene
sono abituato con altra situazione
pistola di si vive così simile va bene e
così si dava alle 9 incredibile ragazze
se le merita tutte le cause legali se
posso dire va bene
lo spazio sistema la moviola va bene
vediamo come si fa vediamo prego sono
forte grazie ma anche bello e quindi ma
scusi ma proprio in mille persone con
casi non si capisce più niente ma porca
vacca
come faccio a fare fallo sempre corti
nel lato sinistro a occhetto approvato
ai marinai a difficilissimo porca vacca
entro un competitiva ma poi ha fatto
veramente bene c'è anche la renauto
persi per essere un accesso devo dire
non mai a porca vacca no gg
no ma non vedevo la porta ma io non vedo
nè la porta c'è un piccolo problema di
prospettiva
madonna ero convintissimo nielsen
importa fa convintissimo proprio dettato
km zero
mamma mia e cardascio gente online è
forte si deve l r non vedo l'ora mi
metto gli atleti in porta faccio prima
mamma viene dopo le 20 volte lei crede
crede che basti fare quello è no invece
niente ragazzi è difficilissimo a donna
mi sento un novellino di condono il
novellino di rocket e dai ma edizione
dalla metà campo attenzione no no niente
può fare la metà campo e figura
l'hack è male che male
mi scusi mi diventa violento così
l'esultanza migliore madonna non capisco
niente e siamo in due
giuro e incapibile madonna ma niente
magico fortissimo paolo si tolga che mio
qua ai a madonna che capendo che tanto
flip and ora l'incantesimo quello
inutile del gioco bruttissimo no era
l'attacco della prima è lo so ma e non
esiste quell'incantesimo sono
inventarono assoluta mesco però posso
recuperarla lei non sa non credo però
come si fa esultare non capisco a ecco
comunque la cupro che in legno che le ho
tirato essi quelle vero parola smontato
mannaia aia si tolga che gol 6 a 3 2
minuti e 30 io ci credo no noi mi ha
detto risulta edifici ci sono un sacco
di comandi con il joystick e non si pone
non si può anche guardare con joystick
alcuni tasti non funzionano a versar
pensi lei perché ci sono dei tasti che
fanno più cose ed in buona recupera e
sono bravo niente io scommetto restando
la colonna sonora il continua a
dimenticare il lo spazio
in tutto questo è un grifondoro lo sa
tagliate male e le corbeau nero va molto
strano ma come si fa a una palla da
lontanissimo
che bravo proprio lui il pelato e per
quello perché perché è esatto e non
posso entrare anche io con la testa
fingendo di essere la palla no non è
vero che poi non ho capito come si fa a
togliere la palla giusta 6 a 6 lo
recupera come succede una passione
veroli era un incantesimo si chiama
illusioni su guardi dov'ero guardi io lo
ero dall'altra parte e niente nei panni
tela macro se sbagli vado e no adesso
devo recuperare il vantaggio ma è solo i
partiti sono in partenza che faccio così
se poi alla fine faccio schifo due
minuti ce la posso fare io sono
veramente estremo in tutto questo perché
se non mi impegno ora che la prima volta
il gioco e ve l'ho detto prima tutto
tranquillo lato spavaldo air one
recupera più questo gioco è maledetto
anche roque tv lo è ahia ahia
il tiro madonna ma perche veloce no mi
ha fregato tantissimo qua come si toglie
la palla maledizione sempre con quello
con questi dire niente che liscio che
liscio liscio gatto no davanti la palla
paro ayane e non riesco a togliergli la
marcia genova layla e saluta l'ha
colpita la porta non è possibile
ho smesso di saperlo o c'è del lager ora
è possibile aiuto aia e che va beh no
perché secondo è si è finalmente 7
assetti e riscalda un minuto barca
miseria un minuto per segnare questa era
difficilissimo che sta veramente sudata
ragazzi minuti dicevamo della prima
parte il che avrebbe veramente creare e
non so se più utile aspettare che
rantola prenda per poi toglierla e lì si
tolga lo vedo la palla ma dov'è
ma qual è la mia porta da sola non ho
capito perché di qua ma equa vengano a
farlo ma basta no cielo c'erano andati
tolta ma lei è tra l'altro in ufficio
della madonna perché sono i capelli eh
sì l'avevo veramente tolta peccato
dio mio
sì perché perché sono forte ottobre è
possibile se non riesce a prenderlo sul
esatto è quello il problema è finita
perché online ci sono gli altri che la
coprono però si è ma c'è uno di 12 b 2 3
b 3 a ok allora uno viola è così tirato
che prima vince brother e no palo bene
come questa l'ho capita e la presa
lavora a mamma mia ma è bravissimo lei
ma dovrà proprio vista al da my mind e
poi a cavolo no io stavo andando da
tutt'altra parte e no anche solo che il
peso di questo anche solo che ti il
primo che la tocca quasi la butta dentro
però se lo chiede molto più facile in
realtà trovo questo più facile dire
liberamente
a parte questo a parte la partenza
ragazzi siamo novero io mi sto
impegnando soprattutto perché siamo 99
ce non la voglio lasciare al caso
ma ancora è infatti vede
no non ho tirato sono scemo dove la
palla non vedo dov'è andato dove andare
sono qua io e ma schivato madonna devo
ancora capire bene come togliere le
palle celebitchy quanto mancano una
ventina di secondi 14 madonna e ieri a
10 10 non è possibile che anzi
creatività come partiamo esatto si mi
mette più in alto più in basso rispetto
alla paranza cambia tutto madonna siete
aiuto 11 10 filippo dove lui maledetto
filippo attenzione che c'è il gran
finale ragazzi e non showdown annuncia
perché non è come il rocket che la palla
di mano a capello complimenti comunque
la ringrazio sono molto contento ha
sfondato le meteore di giorni ci vediamo
in un prossimo episodio di altre cose
con il signor gatto lasciate mi piace
iscrivetevi e noi ci diamo al questo
vino ciao ragazzi
[Musica]